it's about harmonizing and coming
together and that's what you should do
[Music]
fifth harmony is dealing with right now
there's drama with Camila going solo do
you have any advice for girl groups
today I think that the beautiful thing
about DC was none of us came into this
to use it as a platform to go solo we
were just four girls who wanted to sing
right that's it and we were very
supportive of each other
I remember at times someone caught it on
video when I was you know trying to get
my part in the booth and B was actually
in there sitting in the corner in the
booth Y you know trying to help me get
it or it gets whatever this note was but
she was in there supporting me the whole
time so that's the advice that I would
give if you're gonna be in a group being
a group right and if you're coming in it
with other intentions that you need to
be honest about it upfront it's about
communication Oh God
that's the biggest thing that that's a
big one communicate communicate and I
think that that was something that we
struggle with in DC cuz we were so young
[Music]
what would you tell your younger
Destiny's Child so now what advice would
you give yourself
communicate stand up for yourself and
don't lose yourself I think I think it's
very important to keep your own identity
it was so long look at that
it was so young I didn't know none of
this stuff I just wanted to be with my
friends you know to me and be met in
elementary school we were babies we were
babies so I think that you know with any
relationship that you have don't lose
yourself in it you know be in it be a
part of it give yourself an allow
yourself to be open but to protect your
heart and protect your space before I
let you go since we're talking about
groups I feel like the things are a
little different for boy bands like you
know when Justin Timberlake went solo
Harry Styles has gone solo do you think
they have a different path or from your
perception men I don't feel get all
emotional mm-hmm and then their bags
about stuff they like a men listen I'm
about to go do this album over here I'm
on a job later